Harry Potter saved the world from
Voldemort and some here to say he may
have say Florida from the worst effects
of the financial crisis when US tourism
slumped in 2010 along with the rest of
the economy Universal Orlando Resort
placed an estimated 265 million dollar
bet on the Wizarding World of Harry
Potter
since then visits to the city have
reached record levels and more tourists
mean more jobs the recovery was stronger
because not only did the Harry Potter
exhibit need employees but there was a
multiplier that brought the need for new
hires at surrounding resorts and hotels
among the hardest hit by the foreclosure
crisis Florida's unemployment rate
peaked at eleven point four percent in
2010
now it's dropped below the national
average today the state leads the
country and job growth beyond just
low-wage amusement park jobs by getting
those jobs brought to the market we are
increasing the demand for housing and
for other services and trades that were
higher paying sectors with the expansion
of Diagon Alley and Hogwarts Express
slated to open in the next few weeks
fans of the 25 billion dollar franchise
have new reason to travel to Orlando
by plane or by broom but asked local
officials and they'll tell you Harry is
not the only one waving a wand for the
economy there was already a Magic
Kingdom in Orlando we reported 59
million visitors last year more than any
destination in the United States you
don't accomplish that on the backs of
any one reason it really has to take
everything combined not to be outdone by
Universal Disney World just unveiled
parts of the new Fantasyland in its
Magic Kingdom park and also SeaWorld
Legoland and the Orlando Eye all
recently broke ground you're a really
good teacher Harry but whether you're a
fan of Harry Potter or Mickey Mouse the
real winner in the story tale of
competition is the Florida economy
you
[Music]